head over to
losingmymind.com to check out our latest
song genocide support our work now onto
the show
Joe Biden gives a speech where he says
that the dangerous Maga Republicans they
must be stopped they're a threat to this
country from The Daily Mail Republican
candidates kids are almost killed after
gunman opens fire at his North Carolina
home with bullet Landing a few feet from
where they slept after Democrat rival
filmed campaign ad outside his property
remember Lee zeldon not only uh he was
he was attacked on stage didn't didn't
someone go to his house and there was
like a shootout
was that zeldin's house I think there
was a stray bullet that hit his house
people outside because we're shooting in
the bullet went his house yep so this is
uh
the reality a bullet landed in Pat
harrigan's Hickory North Carolina home I
believe it was his parents home but his
kids were there his children and parents
were inside at the time but no one was
injured the FBI are now investigating
the ballistics according to a local
Report Green Beret Harrigan wears a
bulletproof vest and has been targeted
by threats his Democrat opponent Jeff
Jackson has pulled in pulled an ad shot
outside his home
like come on dude but Tim Biden says
that Mega Republicans are the biggest
threat to our safety
does anyone has anyone worried that a
group like any sane person worried a
group of Maga Republicans are going to
go out and like Rampage through a city
with with masks and fire bombs and
molotovs where you know fighting with
cops I'm not I'm worried about nobody
false flags and international
corporations doing stuff no the reality
is you'll be a trump supporter driving
your truck through a city waving your
little Trump flag and then you'll Park
and get out and some far left psychopath
will put two bullets in your chest
or you'll be running for office and
somebody will fire a gun into your
parents home nearly hitting your
children
but Joe Biden wants to come out so I was
watching uh there's this clip from MSNBC
of Bill Maher funny Bill Maher said two
years ago Civil War can't happen now
he's saying it is happening
um
he's he's he said that he's like it's
it's the it's the right the violent
Reddit from the right that's making this
happen I mean there was a drag drag
queen Story Hour and they attacked it I
guess and I'm just like amazing Bill
amazing you have no idea what you're
talking about but to come out and climb
at the people who almost never protest
are the bigger threat than people who
caused over two billion dollars in
damage during the 529 Insurrection
forced the president into a bunker tore
it on the barricades of the White House
set fire to a guard post and set fire to
St John's Church
they did nothing wrong apparently is
that what you're saying and like what
about the person who tried to kill
Kavanaugh one of our Supreme Court
justices they just act like these things
don't ever happen like if we went
through a whole list of all of the
people who've been attacked like you
know that um that young person who was
seeing that hospital bed for wearing a
Maga hat it's like they don't even care
about this stuff they just want to focus
on their message which is that we're a
real danger or how about the kid in uh
where was it was it North Dakota or
where he got run over by the crazy guy
he said that he was part of a Maga a
republican extremist group so he ran him
down
crush them
and then what happened with the charges
related to that was he the the person
who did it he got released on bail
that's right yeah but Cal Rittenhouse
not him he gets locked up for almost
three months in solitary by himself
and in horrible conditions we think he
later came out and spoke about think
about the Covington Catholic situation
a child on a school field trip was
standing minding his own business when
an adult man walked right up to his face
and started banging a drum and the kid
didn't move
and the media took an out of context
clip of the incident blamed the kid for
it and these blue checks across Twitter
started sending death threats to him
okay you get it are we supposed to be
like I know you just threatened to throw
children to a wood chipper base even
though they were the victims but why
don't we come together and have you sit
down have a peaceful conversation I'll
tell you what's funny is we do still
invite them but you need to understand
what these people represent I'm all
about subverting the cultural opponent
but if it was 1936 Nazi Germany and I
started screaming about how evil the
Nazis were I'd be the first one up
against the wall so I'm not playing that
game right now okay well I'd rather be
the guy who didn't salute in that crowd
of people who were saluted I'd rather be
Einstein fled the freakishness and built
something awesome
bailout I guess I don't blame people for
fleeing these cities because of that
stuff to be honest
built a nuclear weapon that he felt
really bad about
that is now bringing us on the brink of
the total Destruction of free Humanity
well it was coming anyway he was just
part of it correct this is actually
really funny real quick just about World
War II is there were a lot of scientists
working on fission or Fusion it was a
fission fission and they were Jewish so
they fled and if Hitler wasn't doing
what he was doing they would have had
the nukes that's crazy they were working
on some crazy technology but then the
scientists fled and then we got them and
then we used them flying saucers like it
it goes deep it's crazy so anyway I say
something oh no I was gonna say
something about earlier about the the
kids wearing Maga hats being attacked I
just think like young people that's
happening not just like college campus
level not just adults but like little
children which is why I think so many
parents are homeschooling now like
homeschooling's exploded since covid
because they see what they're being
taught and also it's like you can't even
be yourself around your friends you're
just going to be bullied by them like so
many young conservatives I mean just
feel like I can't even tell anyone I'm
conservative they need to though that's
it I'm sorry you know it's like do you
believe in it or not are you gonna keep
hiding because the reality is
with with 10 kids
there may be one who's like I can't tell
anybody that I actually feel this way
about these politics because they'll
bully me and then it turns out they all
feel the same way and they're all scared
of each other and this fake lie that
that sits on the surface I find that
there's a tendency to want to people
want to I build an identity for
themselves young people particularly and
sometimes they'll say like I am a fill
in the blank I am a liberal I am a
conservative I am a republican I am a
Christian and they'll like Define a box
with which in they lie and they cannot
then as a result of that can't if they
step out of it then they'll start to
feel guilt so they'll and then other
people will be like well I have an idea
of what I think that box is so you're
that I'm gonna treat you like that and
it's like you can be conservative and
liberal and you can be a liberal
conservative like you don't have to to
stop you don't have to like hide behind
a wall of words or anything it wasn't
always like this I I still remember a
few years ago it was protesters fighting
police officers police officers fighting
protesters but now it's protesters
fighting protesters and and people
getting at each other and I don't think
it was correct me if I'm wrong but but
from my experiences I I don't ever
remember it being this tumultuous
between political parties between the
left wing and the right wing I I don't
remember a time in the 90s where people
would see each other as political
opposites and then really wanted to harm
each other I think we have escalated to
this state which is worrisome and is
only escalating because of just the
nonsense being pushed on by the
corporate media and big Tech social
media which is being controlled by of
course the intelligence agencies that
are calling the shots on what we see so
you know I don't know was there a time
where there was this much I mean
obviously we had a civil war in this
country but that was a very long time
ago but but in recent history what got
us here how how are we here at this
point where you can't even you know
openly talk about politics I was like
really outspoken about my dislike for
George Bush Jr's war in Iraq and
Afghanistan and I would there's talk
directly to George I'm still talking to
you man on the internet like listen up
dude but I never had animosity towards
Republicans I didn't care who you voted
for like if I just wanted to help you
Enlighten you like look at what there
were no weapons of mass destruction that
was a lie they lied to get us into Iraq
look and then people are like oh okay
okay and if you're reasonable and you're
not angry I'm not angry people I'm
actually enjoying like enlightening
people they tend to go for it I think it
was like you're saying that it was big
Tech because it was like in 20 2012
Facebook when they started sending like
the violence to the top of the
algorithmic feed a shooting and then
you'd see and then that would get 60 000
re tweets or like likes or whatever and
uh because it was popular they pushed it
and then it became more popular and it's
easy to hate uh it's a real challenging
to love like it takes a lot of humility
we want to try and talk to regular
people who aren't super political we
want people to hear a message that pulls
them from the cult but I don't think
that means we go to cult leaders and beg
them to have a conversation with us
because they would only exploit it to
expand their cult yeah I tend to have
the conversation with them and if
they're and just just believe that
they're listening whether they're there
or not whether they respond or not I
said my piece you heard it and then let
I'm not I expect nothing I don't expect
you know response or anything like that
but at least you say your piece you
directly confront who you want to
confront and explain yourself
and I feel like the left became really
radical under Obama because when it was
um you know Clinton Bush it was kind of
like they were in the same Club they
were too you know very elitist people
they both kind of had similar views on
things honestly I feel like America was
much more of a center place which in a
way it's like okay good less arguments
and stuff like now but also bad because
we're not actually changing things that
much it's like everybody in this one
class is in the you know political Elite
but then when Obama came I think he was
the first one it was like a true
ideologue who was really had this like
far left-wing agenda and the Republicans
at the time were like no no Obama and
then people thought oh there's gonna be
hope there's gonna be a change we're
going to be so United racism is going to
be gone because it's there's going to be
this black president and then of course
things only got worse they only made the
tensions even worse and they didn't
actually solve anything so then I think
when Trump came along we were like oh my
gosh like we have to counter the things
happening there and I do think normal
people like you were saying want to
discuss things with other people like
all the time I'll talk to someone you
know I grew up in California who's
liberal we'll talk about stuff but I
think like the famous people like you
were saying who are these radical
leftists it's like yeah they don't
they're they're not going to have their
minds changed as much by talking they're
making money changing their minds yeah
when you're making money for espousing
your beliefs it's kind of reinforces the
beliefs whether they're right or wrong
and people will believe wrong idea
beliefs too if they like you if you're
charismatic we have a show where we
invite you know we try to have these
people on we've had a few progressives
so I think we're cool and I'm glad they
came on uh Jen Pearlman she's great uh
Progressive was running in Florida and
we disagreed a lot of things but it's
really cool it's awesome too yeah we do
we she was super cool good conversation
where we actually got to find out where
they're coming from and what led them to
the decisions and thoughts and ideas
that they have and I think we need more
of that but here's the thing someone
like Jan
becomes someone like Tulsi where it's
like you have these ideas and beliefs
you end up trying you try to talk with
people and say we need to solve these
problems you come on a show like Tim
cast IRL and we go well we disagree with
those ideas and they're like but I'm
glad we have the conversation and then
the left calls that person far right and
says they're a conservative now and so
the media writes that I'm a conservative
and conservatives absolutely are like
there's no way Tim's a conservative like
just absolutely not but the media will
just say it because they they want to
take the the well they want to Poison
the Well so you know
my goal what I want to see happen is a
decentralized network individuals all
discussing these ideas the best rise at
the top we solve our problems because
everyone's working towards solving them
the problem with many of these
establishment Elites uniparty Elites
left-wing cultists is that they just
think they're smarter and better than
you Bloomberg says tax the poor because
we're smarter and we know better that's
what the mentality that guides them
which means they will lie for the sake
of gaining power and then the worst part
is they will lie claiming it's you who's
lying it's like that riddle where you
come to a fork in the road and there's
two two guys standing outside one always
lies one that always tells the truth but
they both accuse each other of being the
one who's trying to you know do you
wrong because one's telling you the
truth and one's lying and that's like
the idea of the better men that are like
we need a senate because if the masses
can decide with mob mentality they'll
wreck the country so we need a group of
more intelligent more educated people
that are very stop Gap you're
overthinking but it's like it's to the
extreme now where you're gonna think I'm
a better man I know better than you yeah
maybe there are people that are just
destroyed psychologically on sugar and
they they're incapable of leading I
don't know you're partly right about the
better men thing with the Senate but I
think that was a quote from one person
the idea of the of the federal Senate
being appointed by state legislature by
the state representatives or the state
senate I think it was between the two of
them is that we vote in our state we the
people we have our state then the states
send their representatives to the
federal government the sen the Senate
represents the states so it is up to the
state to decide who represents them so
the state would vote for the person get
it yeah and then the 17th Amendment
changed that and I think that was a huge
mistake we were better off when people
had to know who their local politicians
were
you see these ads about you know
Congress and they're like if you vote
for me I'll clean up the city and I'm
like no you won't you're going to DC and
you go to DC and you're going to vote on
foreign policy taxes and guns and stuff
which is good we need you to do it but
if you want to see your streets cleaned
up you got to vote for your local your
local politicians people don't know that
and this this nationalization of
politics has actually eroded the country
and turned it into some
I don't know what you'd call it the
problem whatever it is today with the
establishment Elites it's because of of
what how we've changed things yeah yeah
you don't want your Senators beholden to
your common your commenters you want
your Senators behold in all new state
legislature uh if anybody I think and
that's I mean I'm saying it
tongue-in-cheek but it's kind of true
like you don't want the mob to tell the
senate what to do the Senate's there to
protect us from the mob we have congress
the people have Congress and they go and
represent your District to the federal
government and then the Senators
represent the states that's why each
state has two no matter what the
population size is even Delaware which
is microscopic and Rhode Island which is
also microscopic and I love when they
come out and they're like when when
Montana gets two senators and I'm like
yeah yeah Delaware gets two senators too
come on I know they have cities and they
have like a million or whatever people
but don't don't come at me in complain
with the size of I'd argue that there's
Wyoming and Montana should have more
votes because of how much land mass they
control and the resources that are
available there one tiny small City
Providence and all they get two senators
it's kind of like the as social media
admins are acting like an unelected
Senate these corporate like how are they
able to veto what we say in public
they have more power than Senators I
think and probably most governments like
Google YouTube like they're a monopoly
they literally control probably the the
speech and what people see of like
millions of people
I mean not to mention you know Facebook
Twitter all these other things and I
mean hopefully things get better but I
do think that a lot of this is is going
to be like mind control as long as
people are so focused on devices which
is why I think people should absolutely
not give their kids like an iPad just to
look at all day how many hours oh last
thing you say no no I was just gonna say
I think that it at first we thought oh
wow technology amazing all of these
things are happening this is great which
is great I get to talk to my family in
India like wow so many changes from just
one generation but I do think there are
so many harmful effects and you can't
just have this like unlimited addiction
to technology thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time